november first the state of nevada will  require all state employees who work at  prisons and health care facilities to be  fully vaccinated the nevada board of  health voted this morning stated those  who do not comply would face  reassignment or administrative leave  board members claim this is necessary to  help prevent the spread of the covet  virus  if there is mass resignations or people  uh that are asked to leave due to their  insubordination um that will certainly  affect the operations of the state state  officials say they are looking into  legal options to fill any vacant  positions that may come up and offer  overtime to those who may have to cover  extra shifts